-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actress
who you know from her work
on "Grey's Anatomy"
and "Killing Eve."
She stars in the new
Disney/Pixar film "Turning Red,"
which is available on Disney+
starting this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-Aah!
-[ Body thuds ]
-Oh.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
This isn't happening!
[ Whimpering ]
[ Sniffs ]
[ Retches ]
[ Whimpering ]
Wake up, wake up, wake up!
-Mei Mei!
-[ Gasps ]
-Is everything okay?
-Don't come in here!
-Honey. What's going on, honey?
Are you sick?
Is it a fever, a stomach ache,
chills, constipation?
-No!
-Wait. Is it...that?
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Sandra Oh, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-People!
-Isn't it lovely?
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Because, last time, we spoke
middle of pandemic.
-Mid-pandemic.
-You were at
your sister's house.
-I was quarantined
for two weeks.
-That's right.
You were all alone.
-I was all alone,
quarantining in North Vancouver
at my sister's.
-Yep.
-And I think, like all of us,
you were a little stir-crazy,
had cabin fever.
And most of the interview is you
running around with the laptop,
showing me your sister's house.
-Yes, yes.
-How did she feel about that?
-She wasn't pleased.
-Yeah.
But it's a bit of reality.
You know what I mean?
'Cause it's, like, beside the --
You know, those cat things
that it's like a little --
It's a carpet thing?
-Yes.
-Right? The ping-pong table
that's beside the piano
in the living room.
-Yeah. It was -- Right.
I should note,
it wasn't a case of you saying,
"Let me show you
the beautiful decor."
It was more like you were like,
"This place is crazy."
So I think your sister
has every right.
I mean, here she is, housing you
through a quarantine,
and yet, there you are,
shaming her house
on national television.
-No, no, no, no.
It's actually more of just being
that perfect little sister.
-Oh. Interesting.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Oh, so, you wanted
to bust her on this?
-She's, like,
a serious lawyer lady.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Right?
You got to put a little bit of,
like, you know, fun in it,
and I think that
I've always provided that
for my family, shamelessly.
-Shamelessly?
-Shamelessly.
-It must be fun to be making --
I mean, obviously,
we talk about family.
This is -- Disney/Pixar
always makes family films,
but this is one about a family.
You play a mother who has
very high hopes for a daughter
who is going through --
like a lot of --
like every kid, like, these
changes of getting older.
And it just seems like
a wonderful film
to have been a part of.
-It is.
You know, our director, Domee,
she won an Oscar
for a short film, "Bao."
She describes it
as "magical puberty."
-Yeah.
-So, when my child, right --
So, it's basically, you know --
"Turning Red" is centered
on a 13-year-old
Chinese Canadian girl
who's going through puberty
and her relationship
with her mom,
which needs to change.
But the metaphor
of the red panda
is, like, the messiness
of puberty and changing.
You see. She's like,
"What is this body?
What is this smell?"
And it's so great to see,
you know,
on any animated --
or any picture.
But like, you know,
a Pixar picture that explores
unabashedly also
the inner life of a girl,
where it's like,
"I don't like myself.
What's going on?
What are these emotions?"
That's really
what it's about, yeah.
-That's a really cool thing
to work on.
-I related so much to the
13-year-old character of Meilin.
But for me, I was like --
You know,
I was just really emotional
and hyperactive.
-Did your family know
what to do with you?
-No, but the thing is,
it's, like, no matter what --
You know, as a parent --
Obviously I play Ming,
the parent.
I don't think that you're ever
going to understand
or be prepared for
when the child changes
and turns into, like,
a hairy beast.
-Yeah.
-And then he's not doing
what you want, you know?
And the reverse, obviously.
It's like, you know --
It's really focusing on
a young person's point of view,
who's just so confused
about this time, you know?
So, the "turning red,"
there's one part of it
I really feel, like,
so proud of,
is that it gives some
sort of language for kids
and for adults to talk about
this time called puberty,
which is gonna come.
A lot of emotions.
And, "You're gonna probably
disappoint me.
I'm probably gonna
disappoint you."
-That's very helpful.
A helpful thing to go through.
When we first met, it was when
you were here doing "SNL."
But before you had hosted "SNL,"
you hosted the Golden Globes
with my friend Andy Samberg,
who is supposed to go
through puberty any day.
-Yeah, finally.
We're waiting.
-We're waiting.
-I thought it would maybe
happen that Globes week.
[ Laughter ]
-It was very stressful.
-But it was a thrilling
combination at the time.
Do you have fond memories
of getting up there with him?
-Well, he has such
great leadership, honestly.
-He really does.
-Yeah, he has great leadership.
And what I was so unfamiliar
with is how you people work,
how you "SNL" people work.
It's crazy.
It's just crazy,
and it's insane.
But it's very, very thrilling.
I thought it was
really, really challenging.
So, you know, the way that he
brought so many of the writers
that are here on your show.
-A lot of our writers
came out for that week.
They had a great time.
-And the way
that you basically do it --
So, basically,
I'm the type of actor
who really, really
would prefer a script.
-Yep.
-And so it was something
that was slid
under the hotel door
on the Saturday night
before the Sunday Globes.
And so I was terrified.
But it was really fun.
-Andy has often complained
to me that there was what
he believed was an A-plus bit
in the Golden Globes.
-Oh, yeah.
-This was the year that
Bradley Cooper and Lady Gaga
were in "A Star is Born."
And there was a scene in that
movie where Jackson Maine,
Bradley Cooper's character,
urinates onstage at the Grammys.
-Yes.
-And Andy wanted to do that
at the Globes.
-Yes.
Yes, I wanted to do that, too.
-Yeah.
-It was gonna be, like -- They
wrote this serious monologue.
I was gonna be talking
with a serious monologue.
And then Andy was -- He had
the costume and everything.
But it's actually really hard
to kind of, like, show pee.
-It's harder
than you think, yeah.
-It's harder than you think.
-There's a certain
kind of khaki
that shows it off the best.
And I know that
from, uh, middle school.
[ Laughter ]
There was a time
where I was turning red.
Yeah, but, like,
there was an actual rig.
I should note that he wasn't
physically doing it.
-No, we went all the way
to, like, rehearsal.
Again, I think, like
"Saturday Night Live,"
you will do bits and skits that,
on the day,
they'll decide to cut.
-My favorite thing about
my friendship with Andy is,
he'll call you really depressed.
And then when you find out
the reason, it's the best.
You know, he's like,
"I'm super bummed."
I'm like, "Oh, what happened?"
He's like, "Aw, they won't
let me do this pee bit
at the Golden Globes."
I'm like,
"I think you're gonna be okay."
Oh, by the way,
can I ask one question?
'Cause we both know him.
He thinks my dog is ugly
and looks like a rat.
-Oh, okay.
-Can I show you
a picture of my dog?
Alright. And you either say
"Andy" if you agree with Andy
or say "Seth"
if you agree with me.
You've never seen my dog.
-I've never seen your dog.
-Ready?
-Yeah, yeah.
Like a rat?
-Yeah.
This is already taking too long.
-Seth.
-Thank you very much.
That's a real --
-I'm focusing on the body.
The body does not look
like a rat.
-What about the face?
-The head does.
-OK. We're gonna be right back.
We have more to talk about.
I'll be right back
with Sandra Oh.